for now Florida joining the fight to get
liberal leaders to pay attention to the
migrant crisis while tearing into
so-called Sanctuary cities Florida
attorney general Ashley Moody joins you
know AJ Moody great to have you how
badly did your Governor Ron DeSantis
just expose the absolute hypocrisy of
the left on this
well it's incredibly important that
these leaders you know their preferred
way to address this is to sit on high
you know issue edicts and opinions deny
deny there's a crisis deny Americans are
dying at record rates every single day
because the borders open and there's
fentanyl you know we can tell you
there's a crisis I've offered as you
know sworn testimony from the border
chief that said this crisis is
unprecedented it's endangering American
lives the lives of migrants but they're
going to ignore that they're going to
deceive people they lie about that so
what else are we supposed to do but take
the border to them since they won't come
come to the Border Biden won't go Kamala
Harris won't go so you know they should
see what's going on so they have to
address their willful ignorance or
calculated evil whatever it is and you
know what really we should have done for
affects so they can really see what
those of us on the front lines are
dealing with on a daily basis the towns
the law enforcement
we should have just put some fentanyl on
there too and see how Martha's Vineyard
would have dealt with fentanyl coming
into their city and how their people
would have dealt with that and how their
their law enforcement would have been
able to handle that
here is more from your Governor really
in a 15 second sound bite summarizes the
entire problem listen
the minute even a small fraction of what
those border towns deal with every day
is brought to their front door they all
of a sudden go berserk and they're so
upset it just shows you you know their
virtue signaling is a fraud but A.G
Moody a potential 2024 opponent of your
Governor the California governor Gavin
Newsom sending a letter urging the doj
to investigate whether the alleged
fraudulent inducement would support
charges of kidnapping yes kidnapping
under relevant state laws so let's play
lawyer here for a second AG Moody by
that reasoning wouldn't the doj have to
investigate the Biden Administration for
doing the exact same thing when it came
to those migrant flights that the Biden
Administration itself sent up here to
Westchester County in New York
exactly the hypocrisy I've been saying
not only have I've been saying I've been
been in court fighting and proving that
they are breaking the law every day when
they have opened these borders when they
are letting people flood in when they
are releasing hundreds of thousands into
our interior every single day they are
breaking the law they've become part of
the cartel conspiracies they're helping
them move it across the country by
moving these people around the United
States
pot kettle
there you go um you mentioned fentanyl
in your earlier answer I want to
extrapolate a little bit on that you're
actually leading a bipartisan Coalition
urging Joe Biden to declare fentanyl a
weapon of mass destruction destruction
what would that classification do A.G
Moody
it's a great question and now it's not
just me calling for this 18 of my
attorney general colleagues around the
nation bipartisan are saying enough is
enough this is such a potent drug and
now because of the destruction of any
sort of security in our border it is
flooding our nation our state it started
killing our citizens in mass casualty
events we have to do something different
I've seen studies that show its ability
to kill large amounts of people just as
someone would do if they were going to
turn this into a weapon a bad actor
working against American interests and
so it's time for this White House to
take notice I know you don't want to
admit that you have failed at the border
that your policies have put us at
greater risk than we have been in
decades but it's time that you step up
and be the president that we need you to
be and declare this a weapon of mass
destruction so the Department of Defense
the office that works against encounters
weapons of mass destructions can begin
to get involved and start targeting
these chemicals before they even get
into our country it's like a plane crash
every day and the administration is not
doing anything about it because they
want to say Face On the Border to your
point
you have bipartisan support for this
it's time for the president to act AG
Ashley Moody thank you very much have a
great weekend I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian
Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis